Speaker 1: All right. I have more to add for you
on the quest for 1.5 million YouTube subscribers.
We are dangerously close. We are now only looks
like 3156 subscribers away from 1.5 million. And
we have a bunch of stuff on the calendar. People
have been writing in saying, David, if you can
get to the 1.5 million sooner, here's what I'm
willing to do. And this is just for fun. Okay,
everybody, relax. It's not like a big deal. People
are just having a good time. All right. If we get
to the 1.5 million by October 4th at sundown, I
will do the Yom Kippur fast. I never do the Yom
Kippur fast. I will do it and I will live. Blog
how bad it is to do the sunset. To sunset fast
for Yom Kippur if we get to the 1.5 million by
October 5th. I will obtain a unicycle and post
a video of me trying to ride a unicycle down the
street. I've never done it. This was suggested by
and from Utah, and now I have other things to add.
If we can get to the 1.5 million by October 10th,
Bowe will get a bag of mangoes tattooed with some
kind of tagline from the show. Bowe says his wife
is a tattoo artist in New York City and he already
has a bunch of tattoos and he's willing to get a
mango The David Pakman Show related tattoo.
If we make it to 1.5 million subscribers by
October 10th, October 12th. Chris is a muralist in
Atlanta, meaning that he paints murals and he says
if we get to 1.5 million by October 12th, which
is his birthday, he will paint a David Pakman show
mural in Atlanta, photograph it and send it to
us. I think that that would be absolutely awesome.
Kurt says that if we get to the 1.5 million by
October 21, he will get a mt. Rushmore tattoo on
his back. Except it'll be Biden, Obama, Clinton,
FDR and me, which kind of scares me. But it sounds
interesting. And then Kelsey says that if we
make it by November 4th, which we really should,
she will bake and decorate a custom vegan The
David Pakman Show cupcake and send pictures. And
one will say Obama and another will be Alex Jones
or whatever. Okay, so she's going to do custom
show related cupcakes. If we make it by November
4th. So two things. One, if you're not subscribed,
please subscribe youtube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. The earlier we get to the 1.5.
The more of these high jinks that we will
be able to engage in. And then secondly,
if you have something to add to the calendar, like
if you want to say, you know, David, if you make
it by October 6th, I will know something.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com